on today's show we talk about how to
report child abuse
who to call and when to call we also
talk about pain
associated with boundaries when your
parents are hurting
when your brother is hurting how do you
love other people and keep your
boundaries
stay tuned
hey what's up this is john with the
doctor john delaney's show i hope you're
doing awesome
if you're not doing awesome hope you're
just doing fine if you're not doing fine
i hope you are getting through today
hope you got some friends you can reach
out to you got somebody you can call and
just say how's it going
we're glad you're here i'm glad you're
here james is glad you're here zach for
sure is glad you're here kelly
probably not she's not glad about many
things in the world
that don't involve margaritas or food
but other than that
not margarita oh yeah i forgot about the
incident
oh that's awesome hey listen out
out in the lobby there's people out here
and it's awesome but
but we got a brave kid out here
his name's gage from florida he's waving
gage rolls in here show him your shirt
man
you don't want to
you don't want to show them your shirt i
i think you should
gage rolls up here with a fender shirt
on
all over james she's all about the
fenders i
as a gibson person my heart ached
but it was well played it was a good
movie looks like a wise young man to me
i know james and his defender get to uh
people who
i don't want to get into it here i'm
gonna get canceled by the by the guitar
culture i'm just saying gibson's and
martin's my kids
on the radio they can hear a song and
they're like dad that's not a gibson or
a martin and i
will just look at my wife and say we're
doing all right we're doing all right
when my kids are in rehab someday i'm
going to tell them like but they could
do this
they could they could they could
decipher the difference between a gibson
and a martin
look here's the deal we're so glad
you're here if you want to be on the
show we talk about mental health
relationships life
which guitars are better gage right
um we are talking about everything and
anything and
here's the big thing the show's for you
okay the show is about you
it's real calls from real people
struggling real stuff and we walk
alongside one another try to figure this
out
give me a call at 1-844-693-3291 that's
one
eight four four six nine three three two
nine one or go to johndaloni.com
show and i just made a little slash mark
with my hand because i don't know why i
did that
go to john delaney.com show fill out the
form it'll go to kelly
and she will get you on the show all
right let's go straight to the phone
city we got a packed show
let's go talk to let's see pam in
jacksonville florida
bam what's going on how can i help hey
john thank you so much for taking my
call today
thank you for calling so what's up so
i've got a close friend whose teenage
daughter has confided in her mom and me
that she thinks her 15 year old best
friend
is being neglected and emotionally
abused by her parents
recently this family moved out of our
area into the colorado area
and the friend has been confiding to her
that she
is living in the unfinished unfinished
basement
while the rest of the family is living
upstairs okay
so it it doesn't appear that there's
adequate heat down there
uh the young lady is they do facetime
chats every day
and she's always bundled up and like
double hoodies and
her face is kind of flushed like you
know she's cold
and she even said the other day that her
lip she tried to use her lip gloss and
it hit froze
over oh man um so she also said that in
in this family
you know full-time ministry um you know
they're not
um in poverty or anything but apparently
she only got a blanket for christmas
and her birthday was recent recently
and she got a candy bar okay so
um this is not uh i i personally know
this family as well from when they lived
here and uh this is not characteristic
of what they
you know portray to the people that they
know so
i tried to try to encourage the young
lady to
try to confirm you know with her friend
uh that this is legit that she's not
maybe just really depressed and
fabricating the story you know for
attention
um from what she can tell you know it
seems to be pretty accurate
um but whenever
uh the the the young gal brings it up
you know she
seems freaked out tries to change the
subject glo
is over you know kind of back pedals a
little bit
if um if the friend tries to ask too
many questions she's
terrified i think of backlash from her
parents if they
you know if someone were to intervene so
so we're just in a quandary as to you
know knowing this information you know
what do we do with it i mean it's really
heavy you know we're very concerned for
her but just don't know what our role is
at this point
i love your heart and i love your
questions and um
and i've had that powerless feeling when
you know you got to do something you got
to say something
but it's far away and it's their hand
and what do you do you know you don't
want to
jump too far but you don't want to not
do anything right so good for you for
reaching out i really appreciate that
all right so the first big thing here
is this other kid who still lives with
you guys who lives around y'all
she is done with the sherlock holmes
business
she cannot be the person trying to dig
and get information she's a child
okay yeah what she needs is adults in
her life
to come over like b-52 bomb
like this is our deal because we're
grown-ups and you're a child you're not
doing this
and i don't mess with and this would be
something you'd have a
a direct sit-down conversation and
possibly even with two sets like so this
is your friend's daughter right
yes yeah i'd recommend you and your
friend sit down with her
and let her know she did the right hard
thing by letting you guys know
she is not to ask any more questions do
any more investigating this is an adult
situation
and if it's not true then
there will be situations to i mean we'll
they'll deal with it there if it is true
adults and this is a bigger deal than
than a kid right
and so i want her to know
adults are acting like adults does that
make sense okay
absolutely so just off the bat there's
something
it's not passing my smell test and i've
just worked with a lot of kids in in
messy situations that doesn't mean it's
not true so if
i'm you what i would do one of two
things
i would call the
um either the non-emergency police line
where she's at and ask the police to do
a welfare check
let them know that you've been you've
received second-hand information
um from a fellow teenager that there's a
young woman who's being forced to live
in her basement
and has no adequate heat it's
not a crime to give your kid a candy bar
for their birthday or a blanket for
christmas right
yeah we said that same thing right um it
can be
it can be uncomfortable and this may be
a great time to show
i mean to have that conversation
especially with your friend she can have
that other daughter
like not everybody grows up like we do
and sometimes all a
family can scratch together as a blanket
and it's a great blessing and it's it's
a gift right
and not everybody gets stuff for for
birthdays and so it could be
a eye-opening experience right
um but it does sound like if there's a
kid being forced to live i think where
they got 28 inches of snow or something
the other day like if they're being
forced to live in a basement no heat
yeah that's that's child abuse
and if the police show up
and realize there is nothing here
um then that kid's gonna have to have
some hard conversation with her parents
and she may be struggling with things
that the parents have been dealing with
for years that nobody knew about right i
come from
my dad was a cop for half my life and a
minister for half my i know what
happened
there's different worlds behind closed
doors right and so
that who knows what's going on but for
you you can sleep at night knowing
i let the people who are trained and
skilled to intervene i let them know
right the other other group you can call
is a local child protective service
and let them know hey we got this
secondhand report
through a friend that this is going on
and we'd really love it if y'all reached
out
here's the challenge they will probably
never let you know what happens
because there's privacy laws you're
dealing with a minor
unless there's uh criminal charges that
that become
public they're probably never going to
tell you what happens
and so it's just one of those things you
got to do the right thing and you're
never going to be able to hold the
outcome here
and then you're going to have to just go
to bed knowing you did the right thing
right
yeah yes yes and not give the young lady
any heads up
at all right that we were going to do
that
i thi if this is in my house here's what
i'm going to do
i'm going to talk to my kid my son my
daughter
about what integrity looks like
and integrity is when you say i'm never
going to tell that means you never tell
but it also means beneath that you do
the right thing even when it's hard
and that sits underneath um
there's a difference between privacy and
secrets right we keep things
private we don't keep secrets right
right and
so what's what's happened to your dog to
your friend's daughter is not by her
hand but in her lap right she had a
great friend and then her friend told
her something and so if i as my kid i'm
gonna tell
him hey we keep things private with our
friends we don't keep secrets like this
i would recommend you tell your friend
hey this is really a scary thing and
i did what i knew to do and i told my
mom and she's probably gonna reach out
and that's teaching her man she that's a
lifelong lesson
and it's going to be uncomfortable that
girl is going to say you violated i hate
you you're what
and those are hard lessons to learn i'd
much rather a 15 year old experience
that
than when she finds out one of her
co-workers when she's an associate vice
president of a company is stealing
and it's going to get her fired for
coming forward i'd rather her have those
muscles flexed
now in the comfort of her mom's home
all of us are faced with those choices
throughout her life i'd rather her start
learning that
stuff now yes okay but not everyone's
going to do that that will be a
gruesome grueling hard phone call for a
15 year old to make
i would all but demand my son dude
i'm sorry so the young lady should make
this call or one of us adults
you're you're saying probably both
together both together
yeah again i would want my son to
practice my daughter to practice
having a hard conversation with their
friend okay right sure
and that may be like hey i got my mom
right here on a facetime
i want you to know i know you're gonna
be mad at me but i'm really worried
about you
and so i told my mom and then that's
when one of the adults can lean in and
say yeah we're worried about you
and we're going to go ahead and make a
phone call i just want you to know that
um okay and um if you get
either i oh i was just kidding and oh is
that real but
then you can have those conversation
that's a conversation to have right
um right you really scared us and this
is not something funny to joke about
this isn't a joke
if you get the if they find out they're
gonna kill me i'm dead whatever then you
for sure have to make that call right
you gotta get the authorities involved
then right right
okay but in any way i want to take this
as a learning opportunity for my
my teenage child that relationships are
messy and hard and sometimes you gotta
do the hard hard thing
and i want them to know that um mom's
got your back
and mom's gonna take this burden from
you you've taken it far enough
and then it's time and then here's
what's gonna happen 25 years i already
gave the work example 25 years there's
gonna be a fight out in the front lawn
of her house
just two teenagers are gonna be fighting
out there
the right thing to do is to call the
authorities in and let them come up
there and solve that problem right not
get out there and get so she's gonna get
a model for what it looks like when you
call the right person and to handle a
problem
um that's good that's good john but i
really
really love your heart here um
and i really love the fact that y'all
are wrestling with this
in a real way that man that's going to
send such a great message to her
daughter it's going to send a great
message to this young woman who's in
colorado now
um and none of this is going to be easy
you betrayed me you lied you swore you
would never tell what
you're right i did and i've had this
same conversation with friends who were
like hey you promised you won't tell
yeah
hey i just heard about so-and-so's kit
i'm sorry man i'm gonna tell i have to
um not even because it's legal because
it's right here's the thing
that guides me whenever the government
has to give you a baseline for
reporting things when the government has
to give you a baseline for hospitality
like when they have to make a law that
says hey these people are allowed in
this building
whoever these people is we should all be
ashamed of ourselves
right if the government says hey if you
hear about this
it's a law you have to tell that's
embarrassing
we should already have a culture of
reporting of taking care of each other
of if my kids are hurting i want
somebody to reach out right
even if they think i'm the source of
their hurt um let's get
all these kids the help and care that
they need and they've got to see in
their lifetime that
adults will step up and do the right
thing i love it pam thank you so much
for that call
let's go to alex right down the street
in nashville tennessee what's up alex
how can i help
hey dr john thanks for taking my call
i'll dive right into my question
here so i'm uh 31 uh
in the process i have a fiance we're in
the process of
planning our wedding and doing the baby
steps just to provide a little context
we're on baby step two
just running through it as quick as we
can getting all your debt paid off
yeah uh picked up a side gig you know
doing good
as far as that concern as far as that's
concerned but where it gets a little
messy is
my family is going through a bit of a
financial hard time
um which is not normal it's just they're
in a bit of a transition period
and i know from listening to the show
the dave ramsey showed that like the
right thing to do is take care of me so
that i'm in a position to take care of
that take care of them or
you know just prioritize my own family
and i understand that but it doesn't
feel good
yeah it doesn't feel good to be making
you know big payments towards my debt
and essentially building
my future but then my parents even
though this situation
you know maybe temporary are not in the
same position
that doesn't emotionally that's hard to
carry
uh that cinder block's hard to carry to
you your analogy look at that look at
you alex
so hey i listen a lot i appreciate that
so
are you feeling this from them or is
this just something you're carrying
around
no no no no it's it's just are they
hitting you up for money
and saying man it must be nice and we
don't have no no not at all
okay yeah not at all uh they i mean
they would want nothing more than you
know me to be able to progress
the way that i have and they're no
there's no ask from them at all this is
just an internal thing
have you ever taken your dad out and
just or your mom
out and just said hey tell me what's
going on things looks like things are
hard
um talk me through it we're both
grown-ups i'm about to get married like
what's going on
could you all have that conversation
yeah so we we have a great
um we have a great rapport with my
parents and i so
i know what's going on basically wow
okay um
you know basically it's just my dad is
in a bit of a career transition
uh you know he's works in automotive
industry things have changed they would
rather
hire you know five people and pay them a
low salary versus higher one and pay
them a high salary so there's a
there's a bit of a transition there and
uh he's working through it and i think
it'll be
fine you know they're not in dire
straits or anything it's just
it doesn't it doesn't feel good it
doesn't feel good to
make a big student loan payment um when
i know that they're
you know just not able to live the way
that they typically live
you know what i mean yeah so how can i
help you man
i just i guess um i i come from a place
where you always take care of your
family and
now that i'm engaged you know even
though we're not married
you know i was always taught that you
know once you are engaged
you take care of your family so i
understand that what i'm doing is taking
care of my family but
not to sound like a broken record i just
i i want to know
how to feel better you know what i mean
how do you balance that you know
how do you how do you balance taking
care of your own family and
while knowing that the other side of the
family is not
on the same page you know yeah so
um how honest do you want me to be with
you
100 are you for real
yeah all right um here's the honest
truth
nothing
when you have when you love somebody
and they're hurting you're gonna hurt
too
when you put up boundaries that are
gonna keep you well
and whole protect your family and not
only protect that sounds so
draconian and dramatic to
um to keep you healthy to keep you alive
to keep you whole
so that you can be in service to other
people when you do that
it hurts because people they they want
to hit their head up against that
boundary or you can look over your
your boundary and see that they're
struggling and
you recognize in your heart you're not
in a shape you're not in any sort of
shape to go there and help them
right and so you're just kind of stuck
and you can be a presence you can be
positive you can
connect but you can't solve their
problem and there's a feeling of
powerlessness there
that just hurts right and
there's something about i wish i had a
less lame word there's something about
growing up you just recognize that
sometimes in life things just suck they
just hurt man
and there's no magic solution other than
to sit next to folks and say i i hate
this for you
and man i've had taken calls you've
probably heard them where
parents are calling their kids begging
for money and they're trying to keep up
a lifestyle they're trying to keep up
with the situation right and
that's even harder but it's easier right
because i can get i can get angry at
those parents for praying on their
children
this isn't that way it just sounds like
you've got a big huge heart you have a
great close family
and you're just watching them kind of
flounder around a little bit and it
hurts
yeah i've kind of learned this year that
sometimes making the best decision
uh hurts the most you know and i think
maybe this is one of these
one of these scenarios yeah so here's
the here's the
typical um and i'm gonna i'm gonna over
stereotype this i'm gonna over
generalize it and over
gender it okay what a lot of guys do in
your situation
is they start flexing and they withdraw
and they just seek out numbing behaviors
whether that's i'm gonna work some more
hours i'm gonna get another side gig
i'm gonna learn the drums i'm gonna
have two extra drinks i'm gonna fill in
the blank right
and what i would challenge you with as
you're entering into
a lifelong commitment as you're entering
off the edge of the you know off the
high dive here
and starting your new marriage i want
you to develop an ability to be
vulnerable with your
with your fiance with your future wife
be vulnerable with your buddies
that you have here in town that you may
still have from college that you have at
work that
are safe and people that you trust but
man start practicing
hey this is hard i'm really struggling
with my parents situation and i'm
sending all this money
you can even sit down your fiance if you
haven't already i'm sure you have but
say i just i know this is going to be
weird but i just need to be vulnerable
and say
i'm really struggling my my parents are
struggling it just
makes me sad and i'm sorry about that
and hopefully she is of the caliber of
person that's going to say
i hate that for you and it's gonna give
you a hug you're gonna watch a show
together and
and do whatever you know i mean go for a
walk whatever the thing is gonna be but
i don't want you to experience this pain
and immediately run from it
okay it can be i appreciate that
all right is that what you're doing yeah
i mean i probably worked 85 hours last
week just getting stay busy
just running yeah yeah working 85 hours
when you're in baby step 2 and you're
trying to for those of you don't know
what that is that's
uh man it sounds like alex and his
fiance are trying to pay off everything
they own be debt free by the time they
get married
um man sometimes you work out 85 hours
right before you get married you're
trying to grind it out and
you know get your debt paid off that
happens but you and i both know
when we double down to work more right
i'm gonna i actually sent a text message
to
the guy that runs everything for me here
and said i'm having a rough couple of
weeks i'm gonna bury myself in work over
the next two months
i said that and i do this for a living
man so this is the pot talking to the
kettle here
but there's something to be said for um
talking to fiance and saying hey i just
need you to know i'm struggling it's not
you
i'm excited about our wedding i'm
excited i love my family i just hate to
see them hurt
and i don't really have a tool set for
that and the tool set is just to sit
there
and um let your feelings be heard and
then you gotta get up and go back to
work right but
it's it's both and not either or is she
somebody you can you can talk to about
it
oh yeah for sure so um we we really
like emphasized communication so i've
had a conversation with her and this is
her response you know the conversation
went a lot
like what you said and she said to me
she said this is
you know what you're feeling right now
is basically why you need to complete
the baby steps
you know because if you complete the
baby steps you know the way that dave
says
when they really do need something we
can be there for them when we have the
baby step three and the four and
you know all those things we can be
there for them when they really need
something
that's that's why we need to do it and
rather you are you are marrying
really well man good for you punching
outside my weight class
way out kicked your coverage on this one
yes that's all that's just a wise person
right
if we will hurt now and do hard things
right now it's going to give us freedom
that no one in our family
even understands later on right and that
doesn't make it easy
maybe you do have the conversation so
let's say your dad doesn't get a job in
the next 24 months
and things get messy right go ahead and
have that conversation now what would
this
look like for us or are our parents ever
going to move in with us that's a good
conversation to have now
right and they can be hypothetical and
they can be funny and they can be
whoa they can live in a tent in the
backyard i mean however you all have
conversations like that but
i'd recommend this using this
opportunity and if you tell your fiance
hey i want to practice
being open about these hard things use
that language with her
um it will give you it will give her
some grace with you when you say things
wrong you stumble over
it will give you permission to kind of
lean into it a little bit and hey listen
spouses
if somebody if some partner comes to you
and says
hey i want to be vulnerable here don't
weaponize that
don't be ugly about it don't make fun of
don't give advice
just sit and be still even if it's not
your picture of masculinity even if it's
not your picture of
why don't you just solve and get over
with don't do that man
i hear a lot guys who are married will
say i finally
was honest i sat down and told my wife
i'm struggling
and she looked at me like i was the
biggest wimp she'd ever seen
it was embarrassing and then she
would go off and tell her girlfriends my
husband's a whiner but don't do that
don't do that man if somebody gets the
courage to be honest
and vulnerable please honor that
that that moment right that pause in
their when they set their armor down
right honor that alex you're in the
right place
man there's nothing that's going to make
this go away and um
i'm grateful for you for having a good
heart good for you man
sit with it be honest and if you can
take your dad out for coffee and just
say hey man how are things
do that it's going to build your bond
with him it's going to give you some
news
community communication skills between
you and him together it's going to be
good so thank you so much for that call
all right listen i was reading this book
i'm rereading it actually i read it
a few years ago at the recommendation of
a doctor just a buddy of mine
it's called uh adult children of
emotionally immature parents
by lindsay gibson adult children of
emotionally immature parents
how to heal from distant rejecting or
self-involved
parents i can just imagine people
driving down the road being like
uh they wrote a book about my parents
this is
a pretty extraordinary read now if my
mom and dad don't listen to this but if
you are
it's every parents in the world but
y'all by the way mom and dad
actually my mom's the only one that
listens to this thing i
want to read this to you and it's going
to sound nerdy but here we go
get this lindsay uh gibson writes here
dr gibson writes
most of the time you wouldn't notice
anything unhealthy about them
these parents however their children may
have trouble either with either
initiative or self-control paradoxically
these very involved hard-working parents
often end up with unmotivated even
depressed
children if you look a bit deeper you
can detect the emotional immaturity in
these upstanding responsible people
get this it shows up in the way they
make assumptions about other people
expecting everyone to want and value the
same things they do
their excessive self-focus manifests as
a conviction that they
quote unquote know what's good for
others they don't experience self-doubt
consciously and prefer to pretend
everything is settled they already have
all the answers
and so the driven parents grow up in an
emotionally depriving environment
right they're so proud of their success
they're so proud of their
so-called independence that they can't
offer their children the unconditional
acceptance
that would give their kids a secure
foundation
from which to go out and to achieve
whether they mean to or not
driven parents make their children feel
evaluated
constantly hear that they make
their kids feel constantly
evaluated right so think of it this way
um the most important thing you can do
for your kids is to see them for who
they
are to connect with them to let them
make their own mistakes
crash and scrape and bleed not crash and
burn
because a crash and burn is a one and
done right your job is to let them
fall off limb number one limb number two
not limb number seven because they don't
bounce back up from that one right
but so many parents have are about
what are the goals what are the the
strategic plans what are the
this is and i need you to look like this
and play like this and sing like this
and you get a a culture and a home a
language in a home of
do more try harder you know what you
should hey
you need to be hey don't forget to and
it's evaluation
and judgments hey if you just hold the
bat this way or you got to kick the ball
with this side
or hit the notes just like this right
you got to study a little bit harder
suddenly a kid can't make their way
through life
now don't be dramatic you've got to have
accountability
you've got to have rules you've got to
encourage and coach and
support your kids no question about that
but one thing i learned with my own kids
is the conversation's
different when i ask myself when i
ask my kid hey would you be interested
in me showing you a few new things
if not no problem or i used to hold the
bat different if you ever wonder how i
used to hold the bat let me know
and sometimes i say cool and they don't
ask
you know what that means i'm gonna stay
out of that conversation right
because my job isn't to make sure my kid
holds the bat well for his four or five
seasons of little league
my job is to make sure my kid knows i
love him
my job isn't to make sure my kid holds
the
bow just right on their violin that's
their violin teacher's job
my job is to make sure my kid knows hey
you need to follow what the teacher does
or we're you're opting out you're
choosing to not practice violently i'm
gonna stop
putting the money in there okay that's
your choice it's your decision
but man i wanna preserve my relationship
with my kid
over their achievement in success and
here's the
here's the the math that doesn't work if
your kid feels anchored into you
then they can jump off the side and
repel into all kinds of adventures
right they can and i'm not saying be
wishy-washy or wimpy
i'm real real strict with my kids
reals probably too much to be honest
with you i
really want my kids to be successful
and it's it's a daily practice for me as
a parent to remember
their success is gonna come from the
fact that they know they are loved
and they know they are completely
anchored in and that
from that anchoring they can do anything
not from my constant badgering and
fighting and i know what's best for you
you know what the way i got through my
childhood good god almighty
and the way i got through my childhood
years and years ago they live in a
different ecosystem than i do
so we're going to talk about principles
we're going to talk about values
we talk about consequences and
accountability and all that's going to
be anchored in
one place i love you i'm emotionally
stable
you are welcome here always i value you
always
now you want to see how dad used to hold
that bat you want to see how mom used to
play the piano
the way she moved her hand would be
happy to tell you if all you have to do
is ask
right check this book out it's
incredible
adult children of emotionally immature
parents will link to it in the show
notes way to go dr lindsey gibson it's
incredible
all right let's take one more call let's
go to samantha in seattle washington
samantha what up hi dr
d how are you excited to talk to you i'm
excited for you
to talk to you so what's up um
well i was calling you um
i wrote down my question so i could have
my thoughts clear here
uh so my older brother is two years
older than me uh he's been using
methamphetamine for
about the last five years that we know
oh it's so hard
yeah i'm sorry and thank you
um so i've watched as his life is just
completely degraded
uh you know first he lost his job and
his home
then he was charged with felonies and
recently his marriage
and now his three children and i do
carry a lot of guilt
about the children because he
voluntarily surrendered them to cps on
my advice
because they were not in a good
situation anyways it's been a long
uh and hard five years watching this and
i think i've become a little hardened to
the situation and then
sick of hearing how much of a victim he
says he is
but my question for you is how do i set
boundaries that protect my family and my
heart without completely isolating my
brother and appearing heartless
so how do you feel like you tell me
about how you feel heartless
well you know he'll call me in
situations um
and you know they're always really long
stories that you would just never even
believe what happened to him
and you know he never asks me for money
or anything like that we live in
different states
um but you know it's hard for me not to
say like well
you did because everything is always
everyone else's fault you know he always
plays the victim my wife kicked me out
my wife did this to me
yeah you know this person stole my stuff
and it's just always the same story i've
asked him several times like are you
tired yet like aren't you tired of where
you're
at and then he feels attacked and says i
don't understand him and
you know i'm a prosecutor and my
husband's a police officer and oh
sweet yeah we we know exactly what this
looks like and so for me i'm just like
you know i i want to be there for him uh
particularly because i'm still really
involved in my niece's life his children
so
give me that language what or paint me a
picture of this
what does really involved mean
with my nieces no when you say you want
to be involved with your brother what
does that mean
pay me a picture of that
well i want to be able to listen to him
and know what he's going through
you know it's a double-edged sword of
whenever
i do talk to him it's you know i feel
like i'm his emotional dumping ground
yep and i take that on and i know it
affects the way that
you know i am around my family i have
two young children and my husband
and um so i know i take that on and
internalize it but i don't
want to say hey i don't want to talk to
you anymore you can't
call me ever because then i you know
he's homeless and lives out in the
desert so then i always
in the back of my mind i'm like is my
brother alive is he safe
right um so here
i hate this for you and i i i doubly
hate it because i've been there
um not my brother but i've got people
that i love um
and that i've been friends with and
connected to for years and years and
years who've struggled with math
and meth you know this i'm just i'm
saying this out loud for those who
listen
meth takes your soul from the inside out
and it almost um
it's like a how a sock can be pulled
inside out you just watch somebody you
love just
i just can't describe it other than i
just feel like someone just you're
watching them get sucked into a black
hole backwards
and um you know they're in there
somewhere but there's so many
layers and occasionally the layers get
thin
the light can get through and they'll
pick up the phone and they'll call you
and you know what i'm you you sam
samantha like you know like right and
you hear them in there
and you answer that phone and you so bad
want this to be the call
and it never is right and then you find
yourself 45 minutes later and they're
telling you some story about
i was just going there for a quick
minute because i had to pick up a chat
because i did a
quick painting job which you know is
absolutely not what happened
and then it turns into a thing and a
thing and a thing and um
somebody's yeah somebody's still and
then suddenly like
i find myself my hands are clenched my
heart's beating fast i'm so annoyed i
just want to hang up
and then i get my own game like guilt
and shame
spiral right that oh you don't even love
so and so
man i've been there and i hate that for
you
here's what i ultimately did and
had to do and it this is just my n
equals one experiment it's worked out in
my world
okay so this is the best i can tell you
because meth is so hard
the first one is i did come out with
some boundaries saying i
i don't want to hear any more of your
drug stories
okay you can call me anytime i love love
talking to you
but i will not i'm not going to
entertain any more drug stories
i don't want to hear about those
adventures um
and it may take one or two times to like
stop stop i've already told you and this
isn't a calm conversation this isn't in
that
in a um right
yeah you know what i'm talking about
yeah it's not when the i call it when
the weed eater's going right when it's
just
not in that moment because they can't
hear anything in that moment right
and um but i'm not gonna hear any more
drug stories
i love to hear about how you're doing
where you're living how's the desert
right
and one of my most common responses
is i'm so sorry i love you that's it
where i made i think the most long-term
impact was i wrote a lot of letters
and people who listen to the show know i
say that a lot and here's why
when somebody's dealing with criminal
activity when someone's especially
dealing with any sort of addiction
drugs um pornography whatever the thing
is right
is whenever somebody even approaches
that addiction
every wall every piece of armor comes
flying up you know this you're a
prosecutor right
yeah um what a letter let somebody do
is it gives them something to go back to
and go back to and go back to
so their initial like when you say
aren't you just tired yet then the boom
all the
all the walls come up all the attacks
the arrows just start flying towards you
and you're like what did i do what did i
do
yeah right exactly when you have a
letter
they read that letter and they get one
paragraph in
or your brother i won't say they your
brother's going to read one one
paragraph in
boom all the walls are going to go up
he's going to start shooting arrows be
shooting at a piece of paper
and he may throw that paper away and
then next month he's going to get
another letter from you
and he may do it again over time he's
going to know two things
she kept writing me she kept sending
something
and the second thing is eventually he's
going to read a whole letter and be like
she sucks who does she think she is
fancy lawyer
but then one day he's gonna read that
same letter again another day's gonna be
that same letter again
and over time kind of like how water
just drips through limestone it's gonna
make its way down
and that pool down there will get deeper
and deeper and deeper and you know as
well as i do
um the other end of meth is usually one
of two things
right somebody like you said just gets
exhausted and says enough's enough and
they're gonna do the hard work and get
cleaned up
or it's got a really tragic ending and
that's where you have to do the hard
stuff right so we just talked about your
relationship there
you have to make sure you got really
good boundaries at home and i had to do
some work on myself
what i found in myself was i had my own
addictive stuff i just got paid for mine
right because mine's culturally
acceptable right i went to grad school
not saying you went to law school but
maybe right um
i did come up to seattle to get away
from
stuff happening in las vegas there you
go right you nailed it
um so uh i worked with a lot of law
students
who once they took a breath realized
they were running too
they're just running towards something
that the world said is going to make you
some money
but addiction is addiction as addiction
is addiction running from traumas
running from trauma is running from
trauma
right now if you have to pick math or
law school go to law school for god's
sake right but
um there is something about us doing our
own work on ourselves
i got two phds for crying out loud don't
tell me i wasn't running for something
right
so yeah um we're all running most of us
and i had to do my own work which then
made
those boundaries easier for me once i
wasn't feeling so guilty all the time
once i didn't feel like i was my job to
make sure somebody else was doing okay
and purchasing a pair right all that
stuff
man then i could breathe and i could
just say i'm so sorry i love you
and when there was some wild story about
somebody broke into my trailer i finally
got a trailer from this guy named tom
for a
hundred dollars and then but somebody
he's like man i'm so sorry
i love you and i didn't have to solve it
i didn't have to
you know what i mean and it just gave me
so much peace and then one by one over
the course of five years 10 years 15
years
i've got great great relationships with
every single one of those people
and my again mine's a fairy tale right i
didn't have anybody die i didn't have
anybody fall off
all the way off where they couldn't come
back and can i be real honest with you
into vulnerable world there were some
seasons when
some of my friends who people i loved
were caught in addiction and they called
me out on my crap too
right yeah they would occasionally drop
like oh you think you're better than me
i'd be like no then i'd get up and hang
up the phone and i'd think
why do i think i'm better than somebody
struggle right i had to deal with my own
stuff
right and so that relationship went both
ways
for a long long time of course you carry
the the burden of that on your shoulders
right you carry the most of it but
um yeah i mean him and i we definitely
talk about
those things because you know he'll say
you don't understand or it must be nice
to say that in your war
pals um and so we've talked about those
things and you know i've told them i'm
never going to apologize for where i'm
at i worked hard to get here
and you don't get to make me feel guilty
about that and so let me tell you this
for him he is dragging you
into deep deep muddy water
and so when an addict comes at you and
says
it must be nice in your warm house
that's when you can just simply
because that sets off your alarm right
that sets you like hey listen buddy i
and don't respond to that attack
just say i'm so sorry it's cold
i love you and that's that i'm not going
to get in the mud with you i'm just not
i'm not going to give you that
and folks who come up in trauma systems
foster
folks who come up in a messy childhood
man when somebody wants to drag you into
a fight i'm coming baby right
what happens is you end up in a fight
that you can't win
they don't want to fight you anyway it's
the only language they have
and you both end up disgusted and
exhausted and covered mud
solves nothing right so that simple
oh it must be nice you know yeah it is
nice here
i'm sorry it's cold where you are that's
it the end of the sentence
right i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
receive a tax from an addict i'm just
not because i know that's not where
their heart is
i know there's different parts of their
brain hollering out at me it's not them
it's not in their soul
so be it right and sam i know
samantha i called you sam like we're
bros sam
um i know no no that's so hard
and i can be you can be honest here
i'm willing to bet you carries a little
bit extra shame because of your job
you're a prosecutor
you see your brother's face every day
when you go to work
you're a thousand miles away from him
and you see his face every day when you
go to work
your husband sees his face every day as
a police officer when he goes to work
and that makes it extra hard that makes
it extra extra hard
do the work on yourself draw those firm
boundaries when the helicopter is
quiet right when the when the weed
eater's off
don't listen to anymore don't be a
dumping ground anymore
and just simply respond with i'm so
sorry it's cold
so sorry you're hungry and make sure you
get on the letter riding wagon
when you're when the when the light
finally shines through the shutters
in your brother's heart he's gonna see
that stack over in the corner
of those letters that sam kept sending
kept sending kept sending kept sending
whoa we'll be thinking about you
samantha i've been there it's uh so hard
um we'll be thinking about you all right
thank you so much for that call
all right as we wrap up today listen
gage defender playing
young man from the audience i said i
you can pick any song in the world and
you are going to get the song of the day
here's the song he picked actually some
nashville residents
they're two super handsome guys it's
kind of annoying that they look so good
and they're so talented
they go by the band name for king and
country and it's off to burn the ship's
album
the song is called god only knows this
is for my new friend gage
and here's what he here's what the the
song lyrics go here's how they go
wide awake while the world is sound
asleep and too afraid of what
might show up while you're dreaming
nobody nobody sees you
nobody would believe you and every day
you try to pick up all the pieces
all the memories they somehow never
leave you nobody sees you
and nobody would believe you and god
only knows what you've been through and
god only knows what they say about you
and god only knows how it's killing you
but there's a kind of love that god only
knows
there's a kind of love that god only
knows
[Music]
gage great song i've never listened to
it but i'm going to after this show
this has been the dr john dolone show
you